you just chose the eight mile hike in
the rain which actually turned out to be
a four mile hike in the rain because it
was raining and I was slightly miserable
but a lot of fun when you're sick of
this hike just click on that annotation
and it'll take you back to the menu to
choose a new fun adventure we are going
on an extremely long hike it's
approximately eight miles per equation
that egg sandwich is good there's an egg
sandwich on our dashboard we are going
to pick up our new friend John George of
my backpack it's pretty safe yeah I got
it hello everyone I'm about to embark
I'm journey notice the Atacama cambiar
via balls hike by to do the helicopter
at falls hike eight miles in a round
trip on the Colorado and this is our
tour guide Johnny and this is our best
friend forever Junction huh and that was
a rooster and this is Brianne hi sweet
sweet hike
we are already lagging behind like in
this small chance my died starting now
who wants to bet there will be an injury
and it'll be a pretty far in I forgot my
ipod nano pedometer so I don't know how
far we've gone no idea I do not want
this to be a viral video on youtube so
you better be careful are you going to
sell it you go like this it's fine good
yeah no it's sharp supershot pick one
stand up for the big flat roof like that
dick can hold up to like 800 pounds it's
super strong you should think about
doing that on the way back
okay I'm not stick don't give him the
stick what are you doing now voila Oh
Baba grand chomp on that no we're gonna
eat that eat it now taking the lead I'm
leading this trail pack to survival oh
gosh what if all i need to stop logging
uh oh that that feels like some ring nut
but is raining super hot
mile deep see everything
this is the solar
you're hiking here
10 strip it rained the entire way here
so we
crossing the river
nature IJ in the house so now that works
about ready to end it turns into a
gloriously beautiful day
did it we're still alive and there's no
injuries although I did to fall into a
slight set of Rapids bringing how you
feeling girl